a lot of interesting discussions on the David
Pakman show, Reddit, which you can find@davidpakman.com
slash R E D D I T Sumner breeze posted vote
blue no matter who except for racist New York
billionaire mayors who stop and frisk minorities,
senile dementia patients who were creepy to
women and want to cut social security. CIA
agents who fixed bread prices lie about supporting
single payer health care and are funded by
billionaires. And anyway, the point is we
get to, so who do we have left folks of a
viewer who clearly is concerned that uh, I
guess litmus tests being applied in the democratic
primary, ignoring that maybe all of these
folks are better than Trump, will lead to
a Trump reelection.
An interesting post, although I'm not 100%
sure of the message. As I've said before,
if the candidate is better than Trump, I will
vote for the candidate. A used or music writer
posted Willa contested convention screw over
Bernie Sanders. Again saying with so many
contenders fighting for delegates, it's looking
increasingly likely that no one candidate
will receive a plurality of the delegates.
I think they mean a majority. If Bernie ultimately
wins the most delegates but falls short of
the 51% requirement, does this mean the DNC
superdelegates will likely be given the chance
to flock to one of the establishment friendly
candidates? I'm wondering if a contested convention
pretty much means we are screwed all over
again. The answer is probably yes, but it's
still early. We've had two primaries. We've
got a third one coming soon, a fourth one
then super Tuesday. It is true that the most
likely scenario right now, and we'll get into
this in more detail, according to five 38
is a situation where no one gets 50% plus
one.
That doesn't necessarily lead to a contested
convention with a second round of voting because
there can be negotiations that happen between
the last primary and the first boat where
one candidate will uh, direct their delegates
to support somebody else. But yes, if it goes
to a second round, that is the most likely
scenario. Lastly, a post on the Reddit that
says, why? Oh, why is tool C still here for
some no shot candidates, I get their reasons.
Stire has a lot of money. Klobuchar had good
results in New Hampshire. Warren is somewhat
viable, but not for long. But tools. See,
there are more reasons to stay in than winning.
I get that media attention, name recognition,
but why stay in when you are only losing.
You will be known as a loser and Progressive's
will see you as someone taking votes away
from Bernie. Listen, anybody who wants to
run for president should run.
Anybody who wants to stay in should stay in.
I actually don't really worry much about tools
are getting out at this point. Like she's
literally pulling zero delegates. She has
a path to zero delegates. She's not on the
debate stage. I don't know that she's running
ads. I don't see or hear anything about tools.
See, except people tweeting me, so I'm not
even really worried about what tools he does.
Join the discussion@davidpakman.com slash
Reddit